[Music]
looking to take the next step in your
career the UK government is hiring and
is now inviting applications for prime
minister this recruitment video was
produced by two comedians but the joke
started before Liz truss resigned
[Music]
one UK newspaper started live streaming
a lettuce to see if it would last longer
than truss as prime minister it did
there's been this mock Airbnb listing of
Downing Street and this tweet from an
unofficial account of the Downing Street
cat
from political cartoons to the TV show
spitting image britons enjoyed a long
history of political satire comedians
say it plays an important role in a
functioning democracy a lot of comedians
kind of find their path by just tweeting
at the time as things happen so it's
really about getting a small point
across in a really quick way and I often
think that it might sound as a joke or a
man but it actually kind of opens doors
for a lot of people to investigate more
and find out more about what is actually
happening in the political environment
as well no previous experience is
necessary and don't worry about having a
high IQ it's been a turbulent few weeks
in British politics Liz the lettuce is
no more
[Music]
but political satire is at least alive
and kicking in the UK Victoria gate and
B Al Jazeera